this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends you know I love better
help and how much I have benefited from
them mentally because having a therapist
at my fingertips when I need them and
not just a therapist a licensed
therapist has helped me out so much
better help connect you with the
licensed therapist who can take you on
that journey of self-discovery from
wherever you are if you're thinking
about starting therapy give better help
but try it's entirely online designed to
be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questioner to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge
discover your potential With Better
Health visit betterhelp.com genius today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help atop.com genius my lovely
genius farts this podcast is brought to
you by Factor what is factor factor is
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit and man well I tell you their
options are delicious 34 plus Chef
prepared dietitian approved weekly
options so you won't get palette fatigue
a whole bunch of stuff you can't stop
won't stop gotta keep on eating baby and
the best part about this is that it's
ready to make good to go super delicious
head to
factorymeals.com50 and use code genius
bring 50 to get 50 off your first box
that's code geniusbrain50 at
factorials.com genius spray 50 to get 50
off your first box the weird thing is
like she wants to be a ninja but she
keeps referencing Chinatown Chinese
oh no
wait so she's an actual comedian though
hold on a second she is wait she's not
even a comedian okay so somebody wrote
this on Reddit so let me fill in the
lore the woman in the video is in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the dog
you know what you just reminding me of
you know what I saw for the first time
uh it's just it's like this white girl
she's a comedian and she made a song
about being a ninja
have you not heard of this no recently
I thought I was the only one dog it goes
I wonder
you got to hear this [__] well she's
she's [__] around and she's serious I
think she's [__] she's a comedian
okay but it's it's [__] racist and
hilarious oh it's racist okay
I think she's a comedian but it's hella
racist yeah it's a white girl blonde
white girl
[Music]
thank you all right kind of slapping
sounds like a [__] theme song to like
a 80s action show or something
I shut my Murphy bed sat down to scratch
my head what could this day bring it
could be anything oh so like she's a
regular clothes I thought it was she
gonna be like in a ninja outfit
[Music]
my jeep that Chow is such a creep I
gotta find a way to take down
[Music]
you know what maybe I poop could be
ninja
I want to be Ninja
[Music]
no the accident everything
out of nowhere
and what is this is there like a
stand-up show that she's doing like why
is she in like a dress at a four like
looks like a formal event dog I don't
[__] I need the context of this man
but I don't even know what the song is
about I think it's about her getting
dumped or something but now she needs to
train like a ninja
dog there's videos of her performing the
song at like Chinese events the Chinese
people hired her oh my [__] well I
that's even worse the fact that [__]
ninjas are from Japan that's what I'm
saying it's hilarious it's so blatantly
racist it's actually [__] funny
I saw this I could I thought it was like
a video yeah
from like the 80s
but then she said Netflix I'm like wait
hold on a second this was recent damn
that is that is [__] wild that is
pretty awful I want to be ninja and
she's like actually [__] going for it
you know original song called I want to
be ninja n-e-e oh no she spelled it that
way too oh it's so weird because in the
beginning of the song it's so normal
she [__] busts out the accent on the
hook out of nowhere like she goes wait I
could be ninja too I want to be ninja
like even even as a
comedy like I swear to God bro you only
get passes when it's on [__] Asian
you shouldn't on Asians like that you
know what I mean
if that wasn't any other ethnic group
like
the worst part about that is is I
couldn't stop laughing and I'm like dude
I should be way more offended yeah
because it's so ridiculous it's like the
most ridiculous thing I've ever seen in
my life how can you not laugh at it
because it's like from [__] left
field it sounds like she's just singing
a [__] song and then all of a sudden
people can be ninja yeah the hook
[__] comes and like yo what what the
[__] is that it's so what is that oh man
never in my life have I heard something
like that but hey you know what though
where I have to give props is the
creativity coming up with us people
might think yo man anybody could come up
with a song like yeah you try you try
making us all like that well the thing
that's really throwing me off is she's
wearing a dress a formal dress and the
audience is in formal wear as well and
it looks like they're in like a ballroom
of sorts or something like that and it's
not like she's on a stage she's like
just on the floor with a mic it looks
like like a [__] intermission in a
wedding or something it's a weird thing
is like she wants to be a ninja but she
keeps referencing Chinatown Chinese
oh no
wait so she's an actual comedian though
hold on a second she is wait she's not
even a comedian okay so somebody wrote
this on Reddit so let me fill in the
lore the woman in the video is Jennifer
Murphy a former Apprentice contestant
and Miss USA finalist okay so several
years ago this video over singing it at
a launch party for her line of Murphy
Beds
those beds that fall into fold into a
wall Murphy bed has lost his trademark
she's not related to The Adventure of
them
uh with a rightfully annoyed Asian woman
standing right in front of her as she
sings it what the [__] does this song
have anything to do with promoting a bed
so she explains the story behind the
song of this video essentially she like
Ryan higa's how to be ninja viral videos
from a while back as well as has an
Asian friend who looks who likes to do
an impression of Mr Chow Ken jeong's
character from The Hangout oh no to be
fair if it wasn't so racist of her to be
doing it I understand how it could just
be her having fun making videos with her
friends so even though then the racism
is still a bit cringy I guess
[Music]
yeah which which has nothing to [__]
do with the bed but the inspiration from
it is she just thought it was funny from
Orion yeah and Ken Jeong yeah wow bro
okay that's but listen she's a Miss USA
pageant contestant she's pretty [__]
dumb
I get it
so we are not in our past in our past
podcast I talked about a dumb person I
know I know she's just twins yes I mean
you could call her Mrs ASAP but come on
bro I'm not giving it a pass I'm just
saying yeah this is where I said like
there are people in this world yeah that
I'm not saying that are stupid as an
insult I'm saying as a matter of fact
and this is a this is one of those
people of oh you're dumb but but the
patch pageant contestants have to be
politically correct like super
politically correct you know are told to
her by her coat that's true [__] hell
[Music]
yeah she's like no no no no no you guys
have to understand this was inspired by
Ryan Higa so it makes it okay yeah
because every person did it and this is
I'm doing the voice of Ken Jeong oh ken
Jong is Korean
Chinatown is Chinese ninjas it's
Japanese no she doesn't even know that
oh God she did this as a commercial for
her wild bro so that that's why they're
all dressed in like formal clothes
because it's a [__] launch event for
[__] that Asian lady in the back looks
pissed and rightfully so how would you
not be if I was [__] standing there I
would have been like [__] what the [__]
I would have stopped that [__] bro I
would have yelled at her like what the
[__] I gotta tell you this though yeah
it's [__] catchy all right well
thanks for ruining my day bro
I did I was perfectly fine with knowing
that that didn't exist you know I didn't
need I did not need to know the
existence of that [__] how crazy is it
that now her her notoriety is not the
missed ninja or not is that what's it
called Miss USA yeah see I called her
Miss ninja it's not Miss USA [__] God
inceptions man it's literally from this
[__] song they go Jennifer Murphy
this is Wikipedia by the way yeah
Jennifer Murphy is an American YouTube
personality and former beauty pageant
she's a YouTuber as well huh hey shout
outs to you man you got balls [__] you
got [__] balls but you're just
[__] stupid
like I said there are people in this
world that it's not that you can't be
mad at them you can be mad but then when
I look at them I go wow you're actually
dumb it's like what else did you expect
yeah you have just even the smallest
idea of what kind of person this is what
else would you expect you're not
arrogant you're not evil you're just
dumb it's just pure it is like there's
nothing behind those eyes it's like when
you if you shook your head it's like two
marbles just clanking around in there
you're [__] dumb how hilarious dude
it reminds me of a conversation that I
had many years back I was talking to
this girl and it was when the Japanese
tsunami happened you know thousands of
people obviously lost their lives and
somehow the conversation came up and I
was like yeah it's [__] devastating
like think about the families you know
of those victims like like kids wives
husbands whatever moms dads
but yeah but what about the dogs I said
excuse me it's like the dogs so many
dogs died I was like okay I I I
understand I understand that like animal
life we're talking about you is kind of
different that's [__] signal but
nobody's talking about the dogs it's
like forget the human I was like
what who am I talking to right now I I
had to I said
I'm done I turned because it was in a
group setting I turned the other ways
but wait ah
but she was dead serious like it was
pure like okay I understand you love
animals but that's inappropriate yeah
thousands of [__] people just lost
their lives like it was like the same
week that this happened you know I'm
like that's [__] horrible it's like
but what about the dogs
and it was so pure but so stupid and I
looked at her I gave her a second
because I'm like is she serious I
couldn't tell
oh [__] she's serious oh [__] that is
[__] wild yeah but those are the type
of people you know it's like it's pure
but at the same time I gotta draw that
hard Line in the Sand bro like that this
just goes to show looks really do go a
very long oh 100 you know in a place
like La especially obviously she's like
a Miss USA beauty pageant she's like you
know like Miss USA people too they're
not really the hottest like I always
looked at them yeah they're not like
they're whatever like yeah you know just
from uh like I'm obviously who am I to
judge but I'm just saying from you know
what we see on Instagram and everything
else yeah these women look substantially
better than them but
you know I was when I was doing um
streaming for a little bit right that
lasted about oh you were doing streaming
yeah I was doing streaming online but
the the [__] twitch and [__] uh-huh
like gaming no no no no it's just
talking uh chatting on YouTube live and
stuff like that yeah so somebody brought
up this question right which was very
very interesting it was
what height
is too short for for the girls in the
chat to date
right and I asked this right and then
you know at first they were giving kind
of like the politically correct answer
right and I say hey I'm not judging you
this is just a live stream like you
could say what [__] ever nobody knows
who you are here that I see in your face
let's just be honest would you date a
short guy I said I said this
would you date somebody who is short who
has everything that you like right or
would you date somebody who's taller
that kind of doesn't have everything
right and they all said taller and I was
like what I was like what if they're the
same height as you is that too short
like way too short
and one girl gave an answer that was
very honest that I really appreciated
and she goes well I kind of don't want
to say I was like look just be honest
just say what you want to say and she
goes I don't know what it is but there's
something about being with a taller guy
that makes me feel safe right it has
nothing to do it's like maybe it's like
it's weird because we now live like in
this 21st Century Century where we don't
we shouldn't have to think about this
type of stuff but it's the idea that
this guy is physically bigger than me
that makes me feel comfortable so but
here's the thing
having a preference is perfectly fine
but once you once you start
discriminating you know because of that
that's a different story it's like this
man oh you're five six Too Short oh
you're 130 pounds too fat
I want you to be 105 pounds I want you
to be more petite now you know it's
there's a preference and then there's
discrimination and like just being
hateful right and it's like come on man
like don't [__] judge somebody based
off a physical [__] trait you know
like you know and this is this is a
really interesting like online debate
that I hear a lot about which is like
the double standard of what women can
say about a guy's physicality versus
what a guy could say about it exactly
and you know it I wouldn't say it
necessarily it hasn't really bothered me
so much but I do understand that double
standard right so for example like a
girl could say oh well he's not really
buff right but if a guy says well you're
too fat it's like how dare you yeah
[__] Judge Me based on my looks I'm a
beautiful person whether I don't give a
[__] what you think yeah it's like but
you literally told him that physically
he's not fit enough to be with us what
I'm saying so it's like that's kind of a
double standard you know when it was put
like that I didn't really think like
that I'm like oh that is a big double
standard there yeah like why why is that
why is that acceptable yeah that's what
I'm saying like once the Discrimination
starts to happen because of physical
traits that's where I gotta kind of draw
the line and be like yo that's yeah
because I'm okay with preferences right
but if yeah if you're I guess you know
if I think about it like that
um from what you know I've I read online
was if you're allowed to vocally State
what your physical preferences are of
the person that you want to be with they
should be able to say the same thing
back to exactly 100 you know 100 because
then it's not hey now the the it's it's
even right it's square up if you're like
oh this guy's kind of too fat and he'd
be like oh you're kind of too fat for me
too yeah and it can't be oh how dare you
say this about my weight so yeah you
said the same thing yeah exactly exactly
you got look if you can dish it you got
to be ready to take it and receive it
you know and it's like it needs to be an
equal playing field you can't you can't
only you can't have your [__] cake
and eat it too you know what I mean like
if you want gender equality with things
then equal playing feel for both it in
in the uh the dating context yeah right
so yeah I mean bro I've seen like you
know people post like messages and [__]
they're like conversations that they
have with people uh that they mean
online dating and the high thing always
comes up and like to the point where
some girls [__] roast a dude because
like first question they ask how tall
are you you know oh I'm like five nine
it's like uh Too Short pass right like
yo you just gonna [__] write off
somebody completely based on that fact
alone five Nine's not too well I get it
it's not I mean it's not a short Jesus
yeah but I'm saying yeah like girls I
mean some girls are like no six two
minimum like I remember back in the day
when you know we would go to clubs or
lounges right I'm not saying I'm The
Pick of the [__] litter but there are
certain people that I know looks wise
that I'm somewhat better than and there
would always be that one girl who I call
the [__] the [__] coochie vulture
that's just hovering around her [__]
friends right you walk up to them she
goes we're good I'm like we yeah
nobody's talking to you and talking to
you exactly all right exactly what the
[__] are you talking about they're like
uh uh no we're okay we're okay there's
there's always the The Gatekeepers you
know what I mean there's this weird
gatekeeper too it's like first of all
nobody's talking to you and like I
remember this time I was at this club
you know it was like a mainly an Asian
club and we're walking by and by the way
I wasn't even trying to hit on [__]
nobody I was trying to up to the bar and
get my drink yeah girl walks up this
[__] salamander-faced [__] walks up
to me right and she just goes we're okay
and I go we're okay with what she goes
we're okay and I'm like
do you think I'm a waiter or something
she goes we don't want to talk to you
I'm like I'm getting a drink get out of
my way she goes oh oh my God I'm so
sorry I'm like what did you think I was
doing he's like you're in front of the
[__] bar right and then her friends
looked over she goes oh she's so sorry
and she her friend started laughing
their ass off like no I didn't know you
want to drink I was like first of all
that's kind of rude yeah dude come on
man you sharing a comments based it now
if I approached you and I [__] said
something I understand the reaction if
I'm in the general vicinity don't
[__] assume I'm trying to talk to you
also too it's like you horse face [__]
unless the only reason why I'll be
coming up to you if they give you a
carrot
you're not [__] hungry Mr Ed I try to
give you a carrot I can't believe she
said that to me let me ask so mean let
me ask you this though was your first
Club experience a good one or a bad one
first one clubbing very awkward very
awkward why because I just didn't know
what to do uh I like I was super awkward
yeah I didn't know how to ask girls to
dance yeah yeah yeah I didn't know what
I was doing I didn't I felt super
[__] insecure it was loud as [__] I
get that I get my first Club experience
was it started off awkward for the same
reasons I'm kind of there I don't know
like what what the vibe is like how to
interact you know I was like all right
you know what [__] it I see you know
girls dancing on the floor just go dance
with him right and I start dancing with
one girl and then like she starts
getting freaky on me like I'm saying
rubbing her [__] poonan between my
little snail Trail on your leg yeah
exactly leaving that [__] snail Trail
and then two of her friends join and
then [__] start getting so I got two
girls [__] rubbing their you know vag
on both my thighs and then another my
experience and then and then one of them
[__] straight grabs my dick I said yo
clubbing is fantastic this is my first
experience nothing that happened to me
that way uh I walked up to a bar to get
a drink and a girl told me yeah
thank you we're good thank you I want a
drink lady and I wasn't even talking to
you
no yeah my first Club experience I was
18 though I went to an 18 and over club
and so I I couldn't get uh alcohol but
let me tell you I wasn't missing out on
the Alcohol because that was you know we
get alcohol
that [__] I just remember just like like
the guys too the creepy guys were always
the weirdest ones like I remember there
was these type of dudes that would just
sit around the club they would never
approach women and they would just be
sitting there just like huh dude I go
hella fine it's like you're not even
talking to them dude you [__] creeps
I know those dudes are [__] weird man
yeah like I it's always guys in the
corner not talking to any girls no one
time I was at a Vegas club right this
dude [__] God is sweet or himself he
had multiple [__] girls because like
you know the he the the uh bouncers or
whatever bring girls in right and then
there were like seven eight girls they
had like Don perion and just [__]
popping bottles this dude just sitting
in the seat hat on sunglasses like hands
in his pocket not even talking to the
girls reap yeah and the girls are just
partying and just [__] basically
partying off his [__] and they just keep
ordering bot I did not see him talk to
because his Booth was right next to ours
you know I'm looking at this dude like
are you doing just flexing like you just
come here because you're [__] bored
you got money and you just sit because
yeah yeah not talking to them not even
looking at them or engaging with them
I'm like that's the [__] weirdest
Flex I've ever seen man see that see
that girl who insulted me that's the guy
you say it too
not me
but he's [__] he's he's giving them
[__] nice bottles though you know
Non-Stop and they're letting them party
for free that's [__] crazy that's
definitely somebody like I've we've
heard people say this a million times
over where it's like if you were a dwee
before you had money you're now you're
just a Dewey with money yeah and you see
that a lot in people right people who
are just like trash human beings who
kind of get money and they get Fame and
then they now they think that they're
one of the cool people so they Flex
super hard San Francisco in a nutshell
after the tech boom all of a sudden you
know like it became a cockfest over
there you had
what you just said like people who
weren't exactly socially Adept didn't
have a lot of friends now they got a lot
of money so what do they do they booked
the movie called Shang Tsung
I have to do it because it's just so
funny man long hanging fruit huh yeah um
no but yeah Chinese food
low hanging Ninja
job but yeah those guys just [__] go
I'm kidding guys by the way I'm [__]
kidding they go around flexing their
wealth because they they don't know what
else to do except that you know yeah and
um I've heard I've heard from like many
girls that live up in the bay like how
[__] lame they are yes they don't
know how to talk about anything except
their wealth and money and their job you
know and then they just want you to know
I got a lot of [__] money bro there's
this one dude he's a an Asian person
that's in the Celebrity Circle everybody
knows who he is I'll tell you if I said
his name you know this [__] dog
like
he is such a [__] dweeb like he he
married I don't know I don't personally
know him like that but when I first met
him all this dude did was talk about his
money the people that he knew oh and you
know like the way people name drop is so
[__] obvious he goes yeah you know
like he was this is not what he said but
he'll be like yeah I'd be hanging out
with you know ush I'm like who's ush oh
you know a shirt like
I realized
[__] doing
but you know obviously now that he has
money he could he could have this
Persona and portray himself a certain
way because a lot of people let him uh
get away with it because they want
things from him yeah I'm just sitting
here just like dog you are such a
[__] dweeb so lame man the people who
[__] do that [__] dude that's that's
what I [__] always hated about like
um being kind of like in entertainment
or like in that La scene like even when
I was doing music you know you rub
shoulders with these types of people
yeah just love to [__] name drop
talking about all this big [__] I'm
sorry did I [__] ask I don't give a
[__] who you're hanging out with or
where you were last night I don't give a
[__] why are you always hearing do that
yeah why volunteering information and by
the way just for people to understand
this there's a difference between a
dweeb and a nerd nerd is cool weed is a
little [__] like nerds means like you
just you know geek out over [__]
things nerds and geek has a positive
connotation to me uh the weeb is a
[__] dwee dude you could be a nerd
and a geek and not be a dweeb dweebs are
that you know what I mean and you it's
like these guys that always think that
they try to pretend like they're cool
all the [__] time and they're so
exhausting man it's like Jesus Christ is
the only thing that you could talk about
is like number one it's like [__] you
[__] uh how much money you have uh what
you're driving it's like listen if I
took all that money away from you you
would be nobody
nobody would be around you but here's
the [__] up thing is that the world
that we live in that's a big factor you
know the fact that they got money they
can do that talk like that act like that
be why because we [__] get worse we
give them the pass we [__] idolize
you know wealth and that type of status
that type of like lifestyle and so
you know it keeps spawning these [__]
creatures and they're all and they're
usually guys it's always these [__]
men that are always the ones that feel
like they have to they have this
perception of what an alpha male is oh
right come on don't even hey man pop G
baby yeah top G top G they'll see
somebody like what he said when he was
in [__] jail and he [__] was
riding with the full headache
bro these do you see what you got on the
top of your head that is not a full head
of hair man that fool got jacked in jail
he was huge yeah
do you have weights in that way
but yeah the full head of hair thing was
hilarious he's like I'm looking in the
mirror now with my full head air it's
like in what world is that a full head
of hair my man that dude but that's the
type of guy that
um Andrew Tate attracts right so Andrew
Tate will say you know the you know the
whole weird thing about Andrew Tate is
like you know people will clip things
where he says something that's very very
smart so you'll see he's not a bad guy
it's like well we could clip a lot of
things from people who say you know
relatively intelligent things but stuff
that they spew that's very hateful and
mean it's not the stuff that we're gonna
agree with you know what I mean so when
he you know tells you know it's like
shut up [__] and go make me a sandwich
it's like oh that's [__] misogynistic
sexist as [__] yeah but here's the thing
too is that like I I'm not gonna say I
firmly believe but I better some would
believe yeah that he's playing a
character he knows what he's doing like
Colby Covington yeah yeah yeah they know
what they're doing they know who Their
audience is and they're just and milking
the [__] out of them and and getting
[__] rich and famous along the way
that arguably might make him even a
worse person right because for sure for
sure like with the ripple effect that he
has on like a young man's mind yeah and
the way that you know they believe that
they are owed like women's affection
because oh I'm a top G I make money this
is how women are going to like me it's
like okay
you think they give a [__] man you think
they have a moral compass like that once
you make that [__] decision that
conscious decision of this is what I'm
gonna be and this is how I'm gonna make
money bro you leave that [__] in the
rear view most of the people that do
talk like that are the ones without
money which is so [__] weird they go
see this is how women are it's like bro
you're not even in the conversation
Andrew Tate doesn't even accept you in
his group yeah you're the [__] loser
you know you're a [__] bottom you're
getting [__] in the ass like he's not
even including you in the conversation
and they're like see what he says about
women it's like no you're not in the
conversation but that's the thing he
gives that sense of confidence you know
he he emboldens these type of people who
like Need A coping mechanism right they
got no [__] love from women no game
with women so what do they think they
become in cells like [__] these women
they don't know what the hell they're
missing out on why because they're
[__] stupid and and I'm I'm too
[__] Alpha for them that's why and
then they they cope they cope with their
inferiority complex you know
that's what these guys know that they're
doing and you know what I've been
watching online that I really [__]
hate that's super [__] annoying it's
like it's like these red pill guys right
well they'll they will interview some of
the dumbest women ever it's like do you
think that these women are
representative of like a majority of the
women in this world I know they are
literally dumb yeah like they make money
by showing their [__] [__] this is
where they put value in themselves I'm
not saying all women are like that that
that are on like only fans or whatever
yeah but the ones that they specifically
bring on to their podcast or shows are
the ones that intellectually cannot
defend themselves vapid and superficial
like exactly like never bring on a woman
who's like who can actually speak up for
herself right and it's just weird
watching them just bully them well
because the thing is it serves their
agenda yeah right I mean that's that's
the game right and then there's that's
why there's so much divisiveness in this
country because social media really
serves as the platform for serving all
of this message a tape message and and
agendas and then it becomes tribe
mentality it's like you're one or the
other but then it's not like you can
have a civil conversation if you're on
the other side I [__] hate you and
you're an idiot right and that's what it
is
um yeah they bring on [__] girls like
that again because see this is how women
are what do you mean women you see she
said it she's a woman like no this isn't
yeah this doesn't represent the average
[__] woman in this country man get
somebody educated with their you know
with proper intellect and thoughts and
and opinions on things like and that's
why by comparison they always look so
intelligent it's like yeah if you're
talking to a doorknob you're gonna look
smart you're gonna be the one who
obviously has more words to say because
the doorknob's not going to say much
right watch these girls are listening to
this podcast like how [__] dare you
it's like well hey you didn't do a good
job [__] defending your gender all
right so what can I say well that's not
their job to do that you know they they
speak for themselves but that they thing
is they just don't do a good very good
job even speaking for themselves yeah
it's not what they're what they're good
at right you know what I mean like they
know it the how they make their money is
bike they bring him in to be a punching
bag let's be honest bro that's what
they're doing yeah that's what I don't
like it's like God damn why you gotta
[__] bully these girls dude yeah
but again they have an agenda to carry
out because it's tied to their status
and their wealth and so they'll
willingly and consciously do it which
again I mean because look man even
things like Fox News Right In in light
of the [__] lawsuit against them
right now a bunch of emails and texts
from the hosts there have been coming
out Tucker Carlson just [__] on
Donald Trump saying what a shitty human
being he is guys like Sean Hannity who
who in public on on the camera are very
supportive are very you know pro-trump
or behind the scenes they're like oh my
[__] god look at this [__] that's
going on when the Insurrection right so
these guys know what the [__] they're
doing they're smart [__] but
they decide to do that because
their Fame and their wealth and their
power is all tied to that it [__]
Clicks in the views yeah yeah it's just
a weird place that we're I mean onto
that topic too because we were talking
about we are going to talk about this
because I wanted it I found this video
[__] genius brain listeners listen up
this spring you need nutritious
convenient meals to energize you for
warmer active days to keep you on track
reaching your goals Factor America's
number one ready to eat meal kit can
help you feel fast with Ready-to-Eat
meals delivered straight to your door
you'll save time eat well and Tackle
everything on your to-do list listen I
will send a bunch of factor meals and I
was very skeptical about this but Factor
meals are actually pretty freaking good
uh when I am on the go and listen I cook
a lot at home but but I got a bunch of
things on my plate the last thing I want
to do is cook and if I can have meals
that are ready made that are freaking
delicious I'm gonna go with factor and
I'm not just saying that look if you're
looking for calorie conscious options
this spring try delicious dietitian
approved calorie smart meals uh if
you're too busy to cook at all with
Factor skip the trip to the grocery
store and Skip chopping prepping and all
that other stuff all you have to do is
heat and enjoy 34 plus Chef prepared
dietitian approved weekly options and
there's always some something new to try
so you will get palette fatigue I
freaking love Factor head to
factormeals.com geniusprain 50 and use
code geniusbrain50 to get 50 off your
first box that's code genius brain50 at
factamils.com50 to get 50 off your first
box this podcast is brought to you by
better help my friends you know me I'm
all about that mental health and genius
brain is sponsored by better health so
getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because
we're growing up and changing all the
time you are not the same person you
were today as you were the day before
that or the person you will be after
that and navigating through life without
therapy has been you know really tough
for a lot of people so therapy is all
about deepening your self-awareness and
understanding if you benefited from from
therapy you guys should know how great
Better Health is because I have
benefited from it and it's just been a
you know daily part of my life listen if
you're thinking about starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get messed with a licensed therapist and
switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com genius today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
help.com genius
there's so many things that are
happening in this video of Takashi 69
getting jumped at a [__] LA Fitness
I don't even understand yeah what the
[__] are you doing in an LA Fitness that
was the first question was I still don't
get it yeah it's like bro you got enough
money to go to Equinox number two why
you got booty cheek shorts on because
he's a [__] troll let's be honest you
can't question anything that guy does
because he's a troll like he knows it
and and like what had happened there
like it was a matter of time like bro
don't ever talk about thuggery anymore
in your life I could see your coochie
through those shorts that's that's the
whole thing right is that His Image how
how he portrays himself and then what he
talks about there's clearly you know a
gap there right
but that's his shtick is just [__]
trolling people and he's been doing that
for you know how many years now what
seven years six years whatever
it was like I said it was bound to catch
up I mean this [__] was trolling
real gangs coming to LA and [__] like
trolling real CR like OG [__] members
right what he would do is he would post
a [__] Instagram story of himself
like at the oh yeah I'm at you know
so-and-so mall right now just chilling
you know and then he'll talk [__] about
these guys but then he was there two
hours ago and he just took video and he
uploaded it so those guys end up going
to the mall right away and then he CR
post another video laughing at them he's
like y'all [__] are stupid I
was there too
it was only a matter of time man you
can't [__] you know keep instigating
like that and you know what the weird
thing is it's like
just reading the comments and what
people like this is what I mean how
I I really do believe people like Andrew
Tate and Takashi 690 call they kind of
fall into the same category because
they're playing this character to fat in
their pockets but they're leaving this
seventy percent of the audience doesn't
even know that yeah right and it's
bringing out the worst in people or
these terrible people are finding
somebody to Champion yeah right so for
example
when they talk about Takashi 69 the
people who love takashi69 the most are a
bunch of clout chasing kids who want to
be him so bad they go what's the problem
with this why can't I do it too yeah and
the the so for example when um obviously
he snitched on everybody right the tray
waking or whatever whatnot right they go
the conversation behind that and
defending him is saying well wouldn't
you do the same it's like listen of
course I would do the same but now
you're bringing up a different
conversation and this is what I mean by
some people are just inherently stupid
they don't understand this concept
bringing up the idea of comparing it to
another person saying would you not
snitch them out of course because number
one we wouldn't have done what he did
and number two we are civilians he was
saying he was a gang member right so you
get what you pay for so what we're
holding him up to is the lifestyle that
he portrayed right not a civilian going
into jail for absolutely no [__]
reason the reason why people are calling
him a pitch a snitch a little [__] and
his argument too he goes my whole life
would have been over with and I would
have went to jail of course but you have
to live the life that you portrayed that
you said was true that is why people are
calling you a [__] not because you
weren't going to go to jail you're not
living up to your own hype but that's
the difference that's the difference
between a character and somebody who's
about that life once [__] gets real then
it's like ah just kidding out that I'm
not about that life that's the weird
thing and people let him talk all all
crazy ways sideways it's like dude just
smack him the [__] up it tears credit
though he did take the beating pretty
well
he took it pretty well yeah I mean he
shelled the [__] up he didn't even fight
back you can't even fight it's crazy
it's like you can't even throw fists I'm
not saying he could have won but he
didn't even swing back it's like [__]
you're a [__] yeah I mean but look man
I saw back [__] come out of that shorts
it again it was just a matter of time
for it to catch up to him I'm surprised
it didn't happen sooner or that it
doesn't happen more frequently and it's
not for the lack of trying people
definitely have tried but he's he's a
security [__] he's yeah security
around him 24. yeah but you know here's
the disturbing thing for me is that when
you have the audiences the fans of these
types of people these types of
characters what you were saying earlier
where they don't know that they're
playing a character
the scarier thing and disturbing thing
for me is they look at that as a formula
for Success yeah this is what this
person did for success and this is the
same yeah this is what I need to do and
then you blur that line between
character and an actual person you know
and then they become that person for
that for the clout Chase for the fame
chase the money Chase all of that
that's what's disturbing to me is that
you're influencing a lot of
impressionable Youth and guys like
Andrew take guys like Colby Covington
guys like you know Takashi 69 who spew
hateful messages and you know it's like
yeah I get it I get what you're doing
you're playing heal you're playing a
character right but at the same time
it's like yeah you put in some very
[__] negative and like divisive [__]
out there I mean here's a crazy thing
right people had that argument that the
internet has made people dumb it's not
the internet has made people dumb it's
that people who weren't allowed to sit
at the table and speak their opinions
now have a platform to speak their
opinions when you have a village idiot
guess what the village tells The Village
Idiot to do to shut the [__] up we go
hey they go we go like we The Village
Chiefs and the civilians were like hey
this is what we should do for the town
yeah and then the [__] Village Idiot
comes out chewing on a stone
the common name for a country-ass
pumpkin in Korea a little touchy that
comes out right yeah the bowl on top of
his head chewing on a rock and he goes
look I have an idea guys and then guess
what the Village People do we go shut
the [__] up and get your [__] dumb
ass back there now
you'll find out that a majority of
idiots are online and now they have a
group and they they find strength in
numbers yeah internet never made people
dumb there was always this amount of
stupid people most people didn't give
stupid people a platform to speak
because the smart people would tell them
to shut the [__] up and now because the
platform exists they're able to band
together you know they're able to get
their message out there you know not not
just to their [__] local town or city
state [__] worldwide on on a
universal level and we have idiots all
around the world regardless of age
gender uh ethnicity background
it's an idiot right but they see this
message from somebody who has because
you can be an idiot and still have
Charisma yeah right you can be an idiot
and still speak well you know uh maybe
what you're speaking about is idiotic
but you just can speak it very well
right
and then they see this person to latch
onto and they're like yeah this this
person is making a lot of [__] sense
right now I [__] with this person and
I'ma support this person and then it can
even evolve into I want to be this
person this is what I [__] need to do
you know he's giving me the blueprint or
she's giving me the blueprint to for me
to get to that level that's the [__]
scary thing yeah you know they they
adopt it as reality
this is such a weird thing to watch man
and like I know people are gonna clip
it's like dude how you how can you call
six nine a little [__] you wouldn't say
it to his face I 100 and I ain't scared
of that little guy plenty of people have
said I mean there's plenty of videos of
yeah it's like what are you talking
about like if it was a legitimate like
gang member and he was about that life I
can't say any of that [__] but he
obviously put it out and said that he's
not so the idea that he was portraying
this character and he's wondering why
people expected him to follow through
with it it's like you're the one who put
it out there hey bro listen all right
you got a [__] chart you know you
have the x-axis and the y-axis you
gotcha find out and you got your [__]
round right the more you [__] around the
more you're gonna find out and once
again only because he said that he was
about that life yeah he's if you say
you're a street dude and you live by the
code of the street you gotta honor the
code of the street right he's calling
other people [__] and saying that
they're not real thugs and it's like
when you were portraying this character
so look they they contradict themselves
constantly they're hypocritical
constantly but doesn't matter it doesn't
matter because it's whatever they need
to say whatever they need to do to
[__] make money get more Fame more
clicks more views that's what they'll do
and that's what he's done and look man I
when I looked at it my reaction was just
more of like well I'm not surprised I'm
so the only thing that surprised me like
I said earlier is that this doesn't
happen more often to this guy yeah
people don't find this guy catch him
slipping
um but look I didn't look at it and
think oh man like you know I want I want
this to happen to him all the time and
like I I wish ill will on this guy you
know what I [__] people like that I
don't even give them the space in my
head like only reason why I know about
this because it popped up like 100 like
I'm not thinking about it exactly
because watching it was like oh that's a
little satisfying yeah yeah it's like
you know you kind of feel like uh this
Justice in the streets was served let's
put it that way right because again this
guy said he's a street dude that's
what's gonna [__] these dudes too
that beat him up not very smart either
it's like you guys too are kind of dummy
let's speak about that let's actually
speak about that because we're in the
culture now right where we have these
fight videos or like all these and the
first thing you see before anything
this just this oh 100 everybody's
everybody's like this you know
what's worse what's happening or the
people who are are they just as bad as
you know let's say again breaking out
well for them too like you know just
very contradictory-wise like they're
beating his ass because he's just clout
chasing little [__] but I'm like you
guys are clout chasing little B words to
you because you were recording it put
your face on it whatever just so you
could gain clout you weren't trying to
beat him up so he could learn a lesson
you wanted to be famous too so you're
upset at him for being you yeah weird
yeah so I say we're this whole [__]
thing is weird Ben and I know I know but
but you know the thing is it's like even
bystanders right who just what why bro
I'm a fan dude no no I saw a [__]
like disturbing video of somebody in the
UK an Uber driver
um this happened recently he parked I
think on somebody's driveway and be in
the back of his car is what looks like a
pretty young I don't know if she's
underage or of age but pretty young
um plastered girl who's passed out and
this guy is getting ready to rape her
and then a guy comes out
sees the dude on his driveway pulls out
the phone he's like what are you doing
bro what are you doing and the guy's
like oh [__] right he got caught and
then he gets out of the back seat and
moves up in the front the guy's just
like confronting him saying what are you
doing bro is like of all like and you're
gonna do this during Ramadan I guess
he's you know uh Muslim right yeah and
he's like you you're doing this in
Ramadan and he's like I'm sorry I'm
sorry but the the guy recording
that's it the only confrontation is what
are you doing and he lets him drive away
he wants to fame for it so like dude the
guy could have [__] raped the girl
down the block then
in a situation like that you don't pull
out your phone and [__] record the
guy you [__] intervene and protect
some because look there's two sides to
this argument of like oh you don't have
to put yourself In Harm's Way who knows
what's going through that person's mind
who might have a
there's that I'm more on the side of
like hey man you see some [__]
heinous [__] that was about to go down
right imagine if that's your sister your
[__] daughter whatever right a friend
you gotta [__] stop this at least
call the [__] put your [__] video
app away and call the [__] cops then
while you're in front of him yeah 100
percent
now Uber
um responded pretty quickly saying they
banned this driver and contacted the
police but the thing is the girl could
have been raped already yeah she could
have been raped [__] a minute later
after this and so that's what I'm asking
what's worse right well not even [__]
what's I mean what he's trying to do is
obviously heinous but are they just as
culpable the people who are not
intervening not trying to stop not
trying to do anything and just sitting
there and [__] recording you know I
mean this is like
you know for me I don't I wonder if the
generation before us also thought about
this with our generation because that
were [__] idiots yeah well look I
don't know if people agree like once
again we live in a very everybody online
seems to be very hyper liberal right
and I tend to lean more uh I'm more
left-leaning as well
um oh you no you both both hyper liberal
hyper-conservatives yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's very equal parts of that it's
weird right like
and I don't know if people are gonna
hate when I say this but I'm just saying
it from a person from being very
speculative I'm trying to understand
right like even every little thing
online from acting television
commercials Hot Topics everything has to
do with
gender it's a weird like I I was
thinking about the other day it's like I
can't escape this thing he's like why
are you why is every little article or
something trying to push this agenda of
what my gender identity is right and I'm
like what is this like who's behind this
well it's a Hot Topic right now right
it's been a hot topic for so [__]
long yeah and
I'm looking at our society of like why
is this the thing like why why is this
being championed right now so [__]
hard
and I'm I'm just kind of curious like I
don't understand what's happening with
Society I don't know if it's a society
as a whole right but maybe it's just for
uh people who are like in LA and New
York and these bigger cities where like
for example
um there was that girl who was a
Collegiate athlete who like almost got
jumped by people because she didn't want
trans
um trans males who turn into females to
compete in female sports saying it's an
unfair advantage and these activists
like barricaded her and threatened her
and then like kept her captive and I'm
like
what the [__] is causing these people to
act this way like what made you think
that that was a good and appropriate
idea right even if you disagreed with
what she thought right for what she was
campaigning for what made you think
trying to cause bodily harm to her was a
thing that you should be able to do in
the name of Justice like what the [__]
are you thinking
one they're just not that bright and two
hypocrisy exists across the board for
anything you know when it serves their
purpose when it serves their agenda it's
legitimate right when other people are
doing it and and it um offends them or
you know it's against their agenda then
no that's not that's not cool right it's
so weird like watching stuff like that
right where I'm like nobody here wants
to listen you know and once again you
know what that girl is campaigning for
you can agree or disagree right but you
should be able to have a civil
discussion with this person and ask them
why before we continue this podcast my
genius brain friends you know we've been
teasing it for quite a while but we got
that genius brain secret society collab
drop-in we got a few hats we got a few
shirt options things are going to be on
pre-order and it's inspired by one of my
favorite animes of all time death no
note inspired by my friends so check it
out stay tuned sign up for the secret
society email
so you know when that's going to drop
we're going to do pre-orders this [__]
is dope as hell we got puff print on the
trucker hats we got puff print on the
shirts the design is amazing I'm super
hyped a lot of anime shirts out there
the quality is so bad I hate it so much
the designs are a little too much
they're too crazy this right here hits
the spot and even if you don't like
anime you're going to love it just
assign for the email I'll let you know
when it drops follow me on Instagram
follow this page and then you guys know
what's up love you very much get ready
for that
one of the things that we should talk
about you know with this whole thing
that's happening especially on the top
of not not so much with like you know
trans athletes and like the controversy
behind that was like uh Bud Lights
um commercial that they put out right
yeah I actually didn't see the
commercial but I saw the cans and was it
only for lgbtq or was it specifically a
trans that I don't know I'm pretty sure
it's like for lgbtq yeah but but if you
want to talk about something that'll
piss off a redneck Jesus Christ yeah
yeah I mean first of all look I felt
like there was definitely pandering
there I mean we see that time and time
again when we had the BLM you saw the
[__] pandering happening with all
these companies and Brands right and I
feel like because that is a a Hot Topic
at the moment there is definitely some
pandering there but then you go from
pandering to triggering right and it
definitely triggered a lot of these
um far right wing uh politicians and and
people and you know you had guys like
Kid Rock coming out with this I don't
know what gun he was holding but he's
like this is what I think about your
camping and then he like just starts
shooting and it's like bro that's so
[__] is so corny you know what that's
some dweebie [__] that's some dweebie
[__] and then there's the [__] the
eye patch politician I forgot what his
name is he's a republican he was saying
yeah this is what I think about
um uh but what like if I have any Bud
Light in the refrigerator I'm gonna get
rid of all of it so he opens his
refrigerator there's no Bud Light first
of all but then he I forgot this other
brand it's the same company that makes
it though he has a bunch of that stocked
in the fridge and he goes well there's
no Bud Light in the video I was like
okay first of all that was [__] lame
second of all I don't think you
understand that that drink that you have
in there is made by the same company so
you should [__] be tossing those too
you know what I mean first of all
you know can I just Express this right
so many people are saying like you know
I saw a bunch of people on Twitter you
know I guess you don't really know your
[__] audience you know I think if you
guys were buying Bud Light in the way
that you were saying that you do they
wouldn't have to do this because company
is about dollar signs and money so they
clearly are trying to reach up tap
market to buy their stuff because you
guys aren't buying it enough
exactly if money was rolling in they
would never ever ever bite the hand that
[__] feeds them for damn sure yeah
they're the pandering is happening for a
reason there's an agenda sales exactly
you know exactly so they're like okay
we've tapped out this Market this Market
isn't really buying our stuff anymore so
let's go ahead and that's the one thing
I don't like people have to understand
these companies don't give a [__] about
your political views and ideas they only
care about money yeah that's it that's
the bottom line This is straight up yeah
you know they just look at it as an
opportunity right I mean that's what it
is it's it's being opportunistic you see
something happening in culture and
Society you're like okay how can we
capitalize on this how can we monetize
this that's what they do they [__]
Pander and you know it's just funny to
me because it's like yeah the pandering
is offensive as well but then the the
people who are getting triggered the
reaction I'm just like
so unnecessary just go about your
[__] day oh yeah Kid Rock what in the
corny ass [__] because the Kid Rock's
been [__] corny though like in coming
out with this [__] time and time
again like that guy is he's a [__]
asshat but you know these other
politicians too man like they're they're
[__] clowns and look again the thing
that [__] pisses me off is
some of these people I'm not going to
say all some of these people know
exactly what the [__] they're doing yeah
you know people like Marjorie Taylor
green and [__] bobert no they don't
they're [__] idiots they're [__]
idiots and the mental gymnastics mental
gymnastics that they go through to say
this some of the [__] that they say
[__] crazy right but some of these
other politicians and people in power
they know man they're pandering to that
base because why money and power right
oh a hundred percent money in power
everything well you know people kind of
get duped by this where they go see
they're actually standing up for
something they don't care they literally
do not care yeah let's let's see if this
happens on a continual basis yeah if
they're continually support continually
have these campaign then you know what
maybe I'll give them the benefit of
Doubt be like okay you know what maybe
they are really trying to make some
change even if it started as pandering
you know maybe it led to something
positive I wonder who was the first gay
person to kind of grab the rainbow for
the gay folks they're like that's our
symbol
I don't know I don't know because I know
like Hawaii's thing is like rainbows and
also Irish people yeah so I wonder what
happened that's a little Deep dive in
history I wonder how they got that I
don't know actually I I never looked
into that I don't know how the rainbow
became the assemble like the gay pride
the the pride of the gay symbol yeah I
don't know maybe just because there's a
lot of colors and it's like representing
you know the different yeah I don't know
I just I just thought it was dumb like
the way like people made such a big deal
out of it it's always so stupid even
Jack Daniels even Jack Daniels had a
backlash from going quote unquote woke I
[__] hate that word so much now dude
because because the [__] you know
these crazy nut Republicans have have
adopted it and everything that they
disagree with there's this woke now
what did Jack Daniels do I think it was
kind of the same thing like had a
campaign with like um
I don't know if it was somebody that you
know is part of the lgbtq community or
like something pandering to that
Community but uh the Jack Daniels
um audience some of the audience or the
fans did not take too kindly to it and
kind of the same thing that so many of
these videos of people throwing out all
their Jack Daniels because they're like
this is what I think about your woke
campaign you know number one Jack
Daniel's doesn't even tastes good number
two Bud Light doesn't even taste oh yeah
I mean I don't know anybody who [__]
asks for a Bud Light or prefers a Bud
Light yeah the weird thing is right when
when you do this and you go okay I'm
gonna make this video to show people
[__] this company right you act like
they [__] burned a [__] orphanage
down you act like that's gonna [__]
do anything to their stock price you
know what happened with Bud Light they
hit a small dip with this backlash and
you know and went back up yep it was
nothing it was a [__] negligible blip
that's not even going to hit the radar
in the grand scheme of things all I did
was remind people that Bud Light was
around yeah exactly so it did what they
did yeah so you [__] showing your
opinion or your thoughts on it and you
saying I'm gonna [__] you know
um throw everything away and and never
support these guys again means
absolutely [__] nothing yeah nobody
[__] so that's what I'm saying just go
about your [__] day you know just go
about your day enjoy what you [__]
enjoy try to be a good person and that's
it man that's it nobody nobody [__]
needs to see your dumb ass talking about
[__] that ultimately doesn't matter man
everybody does that too I don't wonder
why celebrities do that like it's
happened I don't I forgot what it was
too but I saw this happen multiple times
where a company does something and they
throw it in a fire pit and they [__]
light it on fire yeah well here's the
thing right is that they they have this
um idea that they need to record
themselves because
oh yeah I remember the whole Balenciaga
[__] yeah I'll tell you this
I did not like that ad I thought it was
disgusting yeah I'm not burning those
things because it's so much money
I would sell it well you know what yeah
I don't I don't I don't have anything
that's Valencia I still wear Yeezys
you know what I don't they're very
comfortable I I still have them I still
have them they're one of the most
comfortable shoes ever dude they are
comfortable for sure but for me it's
just I yeah I'm not a fan of them
anymore not not because uh you know the
distaste that I have for easy now but
yeah just you know got played out for me
they're so comfortable they're like
clouds they are amazing they feel so
good yeah but
you know it's like the Yeezy thing
doesn't help I I actually we talked
about this when Yeezy was like you know
really [__] going off was yeah I
pretty much the removed all this music
from my playlist you know yeah
because it kind of got to that level
where I'm just like dude whether he's
doing this knowingly to to get more uh
notoriety and attention or whatever or
not it's because he's like mentally ill
and and really needs some help whatever
the cases I can't support it Pam you're
a good man dude I bump his [__] so much
all of his old stuff yeah no look I'm
not saying that he didn't make fire [__]
he did it's still fire something yeah R
Kelly comes on you singing along yes or
no well I don't know I haven't had R
Kelly uh I haven't listened to R Kelly
and all of a sudden
the remix to ignition comes on oh yeah I
mean come on you piece of [__] dude you
know like that's a hey look look what's
catchy is catchy you know what I mean
the ninja is catchy right I'm not saying
that's right
I'm not saying it's right I'm not saying
it's not offensive but you know when
it's catchy it's catchy what are you
gonna do right like we [__] look it's
hard with [__] like that because we grew
up on it you know what I mean it's a
part where there's the Nostalgia Factor
there I feel so guilty too when my
[__] shoulders start moving I'm like
God damn it it's so hard like [__] I
Believe I Can Fly you telling me you got
you [__] that song comes on
you're not you're not feeling lifted in
the air I'm not talking about you know
would you like to come come with me from
Africa
but I will say this I will say this like
knowing what I know about the respective
artists you know
um like Kanye like R Kelly definitely
100 thanks to [__] I can't feel the same
way Michael Jackson never got tainted
because nothing was proven exactly see
MJ is different MJ is different all
allegations like I said I saw a video of
him talking about tatas yeah I'm like
this [__] didn't do it
come on now yeah well hey MJ was a real
[__] though like if you see
someone behind the scenes [__] like some
of the things he says and assess that
dude's a [__] G bro hell yeah you
know and again it was allegations
nothing was look was it weird hell
[__] yeah he was weird was he a
pedophile
can't say you know yet to be proven and
I would rather believe he didn't do it
yeah well he ain't no [__] Bill Cosby
you know what I'm saying like that
[__] Bill Cosby was like a hero
to me so like when that happened that
[__] was actually pretty bad for me
because I like dog when that happened
you know I legit had my favorite comics
on my wall in my room yeah it was uh
Dave Chappelle it was Bill Cosby and
Eddie Murphy those were my three Idols
growing up especially in the comedy
space right yeah his nose is just like
my dad's my dad has Bill Cosby's nose
dude
and I had to take that poster down man I
was like damn man you did hey look
that's not allegedly that's proven you
know it's just um I I guess
kind of [__] up that he didn't spend
the rest of his life in jail to be
honest with you you know for the [__]
that he's done and the lives that he's
ruined that [__] deserves to rot
in jail you know people got a Jackie
Chan knows on him dude
well guys that wraps up this episode of
The Genius brain podcast you just
praying every Sundays at 12 p.m on all
your audio listening stuff and on
YouTube we got the ssgb 20 code for 20
off secret society.com
um one time use but no exclusions you
can get 20 off one item or any item
everything we have our whole catalog yep
change my name is at 12 pm we'll see
y'all next time all right peace